professor you're also the author of Isis
a history when you look at what a travel
ban could do does it actually push more
people into extreme thinking because
they feel left out or can we not do that
correlation any expert on the Middle
East any expert on Isis would tell you
the worst thing you can do is to
basically provide Isis and al-qaeda with
ideological ammunition with motivation
and inspiration the van against seven
countries and sea in an Iraqi refugees
basically it's ineffective that is it
will do more damage than good it will
hardly basically limit the damage any
kind of attacks against the United
States it's counterproductive because it
plays into the narrative of al Qaeda and
Isis it's foolishly irrational it
alienates Muslim public opinion if you
want to fight Isis you don't plump more
than 1 billion Muslims with Islamic
radicalism and al Qaeda and Isis it
deepens anti-american sentiments in the
Muslim world if you tell me what does
the ban do I would say it provides a
massive propaganda boost for Isis and al
Qaeda it plays into their hands it's
sweet music to extremist networks not
just in the Middle East but in the
greater Muslim world well the White
House understand this I don't think so
what we need to understand is that I
don't have to be an expert to tell
Donald Trump that this is irrational
that it's counterproductive that it's
foolishly an American I think what we
need to understand this particular
decision this particular initiative on
the part of Donald Trump is really
Donald Trump is blinded by ideology this
is a political decision it plays into
well with his hardcore narrative but I
mean if you look at what's happening in
the Middle East and the Muslim world you
have anger you have rage and more and
more Muslims now are buying into al
Qaeda and Isis narrative that this is a
war against Islam and Muslims I mean
this is not a war between Islam and the
West this is a war within Islam that is
the fight within Iraq and Syria
it's a war within Islam what Donald
Trump is trying to do is to shift the
narrative this is a war between Islam
and the West professor one is
really sensitive question I say this
with great respect for the literature of
say Albert Hourani in the history of the
Arab people's and all the other
literature on Islam is Donald Trump
running what the Middle East in the
Islamic world would perceive as a new
crusade is there a tinge here within the
rhetoric in the discourse that President
Trump is galloping off to Jerusalem to
fight the fourth fifth or the sixth
crusade you know Tom what I fear the
most is that now you have two parallel
narratives happening and in the world in
the Islamic world and the Western world
on the one hand you have a fringe group
called Isis or Al Qaeda Isis an al Qaeda
that says there is a clash of
civilization between Islam and the West
that this is a clash of civilization
between America which is basically the
leader of the free world and now you
have Donald Trump whose place eclis
trafficking in a similar clash and the
clash is a clash of civilization this is
not about a tiny fringe in the Muslim
world this is a war between Islam and
the West I mean think of what Donald
Trump has said in the past two years
these are not my words Islam hates us
all that is he is talking about America
it's all of us and this is a clash of
civilization so what I fear the most is
that Donald Trump is shifting the debate
from being what's happening in Iraq and
Syria and Afghanistan this is a war
within Islam into being a struggle a
clash between Islam and the West and
that's why I say that Donald Trump is
unwittingly or wittingly playing into
the narrative of al Qaeda and Isis
professor what we react to within the
United States and frankly in a collegial
West is mr. Trudeau stepped up this
weekend in Canada and said our doors are
open to refugees I'm sure he was
awakened last night with the killings in
Quebec is Isis in any way diminished or
should mr. Trudeau and all of us expect
these isolated incidents like Quebec I
mean I think it's not surprising Tom I
mean these incidents have
part of our life whether you're talking
about Istanbul whether you're talking
about the Sinai whether you're talking
about Berlin whether you're talking
about Quebec or whether you're talking
about Florida or whether you're talking
about California there is a real
division now a real cleavage and you
have fringe elements on both sides who
subscribe to this particular clash of
civilization that is between Islam and
the West what but what we're talking
about here and entirely different this
is the United States of America Tom this
is not a Banana Republic when the
president of the United States basically
traffics in a clash of civilization
narrative call it what you mean in the
Muslim world and I know a bit about the
Arab world and the Muslim world it's
seen as a Muslim ban it alienates Muslim
public opinion when when when Donald
Trump the president of the United State
traffics in such a narrative it
undermines the idea of America as a
moral force and also provides ammunition
not just for al Qaeda and Isis it
provides ammunition to the far-right
group in the heart of Europe where I am
in Britain in Germany in France and
other countries that's why it's very
dangerous let me ask you a question I'm
sure Francine is far more knowledgeable
about this than I am should president
Trump speak to Parliament should
president Trump be given the privilege
of speaking at Westminster Hall that
that that space that goes back to 1,000
ad you know Tom really and I appear on
Arab television on daily basis I say
Donald Trump does not speak for the
United States of America
Donald son does not speak for the 340
million Americans there's a real
struggle in the United State and it's
really wonderful to see the debate the
struggle that's shaping in the United
States and the media in particular the
American media standing up and defending
American values the worst thing we can
do and I hear now I'm in the heart of
the UK the worst thing we can do is to
give a platform for this kind of
rhetoric and saddened by the fact that
Theresa May has not stood up in the same
way that Merkel in Germany and the
French president and the Canadian
president this is not a war this is not
a clash between Islam in the West it's
/ within there is a real struggle a
monomeric and I'm talking as an American
there's a clash with an America about
the values we subscribe to the
progressive democratic humanist values
Donald Trump not speak for me does not
speak for millions of Americans